Officer:
What are we gonna do?
♪♪
We'll bring hell down from
on high.
♪♪
(Explosion)
(Gun fire)
♪♪
Congratulations on your first
command.
Evie:
At last.
♪♪
Commander Krause:
I'll always be looking for you,
Evie.
Commander Krause:
Even if I'm a thousand miles
away.
♪♪
(Radio voice)
Air escort to Greyhound.
You will now be out of range of
air cover for the next 5 days.
(Radio voice)
How many crossing does this
make?
This is my first.
(Sonar beeping)
I got something.
Most likely a U-boat.
He's trying to slip under us!
Officer:
Fire!
We have a kill.
(Cheering)
Officer:
Distress rocket, Sir.
♪♪
We have hits directly on the
convoy.
A wolfpack's hunting us.
U-boat, starboard bow!
♪♪
Commander Krause:
We've lost 7 ships and 50 souls.
What you did yesterday, got us
to today.
It's not enough.
♪♪
Fire as they bear!
(Cheering)
(Gunshots)
(Explosion)
Target's disappeared, Sir.
(Sonar beeping)
Here they come.
Officer:
What are we gonna do?
We'll bring hell down from
on high.
♪♪
(Crashing sound)